ma partenaire de ce soir la seule
l'unique l'indétrônable kelly kelly ont
débuté la soirée vous faire disparaître
une bonne fois pour toutes
oui vous êtes ma partenaire est ce que
vous l'acceptez d'accord on y va j'ai
mis ses lentilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en éclats
elle exclut d'élever leurs titres qu'est
ce que vous faites est ce que vous êtes
déjà passé une soirée dans une cage
non pas dans mes souvenirs est ce qu'on
vous a déjà fait disparaître non plus je
n'aime pas un garçon non c'est une
grande première
non pas bien sûr j'ai fait disparaître
des garçons mémoire de quelle manière
même nous le raconter peut-être ballon
rentrer à l'intérieur
rentrée l'intérieur allez-y alors ok
pénétrer dans la cage
vous êtes bien installés à l'est je leur
fais tu de 200 fois je fais rien je
bouge pas oui ne bougeait pas d'accord
tu allais commence à se faire mais ça
comme ça commence bien
bon vous êtes bien salée l'intérieur
ouais ou les que vous apporte un petit
coussin peut-être un souci on peut même
installer la télévision par câble
croyez-moi bas avec plaisir alors que ça
alors on va descendre ce magnifique
tissu alors j'aurai besoin d'une voix du
pdci temps soit la toque papa paddle des
changes elle descend c'est bon mais les
messieurs dans un son qui lie vdev dit
va totalement disparaître et j'ai besoin
de votre attention il ya une formule
magique
nous allons réaliser dans un instant
tous ensemble les chroniqueurs
le public est ce que vous voulez que
kylie disparaissent savez
il ya une formule magique cette formule
c'est à bras cadac à kelly se
transformera je sais c'est un peu
compliqué c'est une petite invention de
ma part mais croyez moi elle me répond
desperate attention 3 2 1 à bras cadart
car normalement
kelly a dit je pense que ça sent
vraiment le pâté mars à 2 3 ap ap
[Applaudissements]
l'ag vous êtes la partie alors
véritablement mais alors je pars
complètement maintenant mais on n'a
perdu qu'à nice où elle souhaite elle ne
sais pas je ne sais pas ouvrez les yeux
parce que tout moment elle pourra rien
t'arriver vous aussi peut-être non non
non non non c'est décerné en tout cas je
vous trouve excellent pour l'instant
vous êtes en direct
[Applaudissements]